So, I just talked about
the organization of concepts and
the relationship of
concepts with each other.
We only come across this when we were
talking about background knowledge in
the previous lesson on
incremental concept learning.
So we had a brick and a wedge.
They were both subclasses of a block.
In general, the organization of
concepts can be much more complex.
So here is a set of concepts that
you're probably all familiar with.
We have different kind of animals,
vertebrates, intervertebrates.
Vertebrates themselves, can be of
different kinds, reptiles, birds,
mammals, and so on.
And here are birds, which can be of
different kinds, eagles, bluebirds,
and penguins,
like we saw in the previous slide.
And generally,
organization of these concepts
can be a little more complicated.
So this is a conceptual hierarchy
that I expect all of your family with
the animals of various kinds, water
breeds and in water breeds, for example.
And vertebrates themselves can be
a different reptiles, but mammals and
birds can be a different kinds, for
example, eagles, bluebirds and penguins.
So these are classes, and
these are sub-classes and super classes.
Now the advantage of this kind of
conceptual organization is that
I can start going in a top down way
establishing and refining each category.
So you see an animal and
you're trying to decide
whether the animal is a bluebird or
an eagle or a penguin.
And you may start, initially,
by saying well, is it a vertebrate?
Then, is it a bird?
And if it is a bird, then is it a eagle,
a bluebird, or penguin?
When you and I do processing of
this kind, it might happen so
fast that we might not be aware of it.
But, when we try to put an air-agent,
we have to make that processing very,
very explicit.
Even among humans, imagine for example,
what happens when the scientist
discovers new kind of species.
Then the scientist can begin from the
top and say, well, is it a vertebrate?
Where exactly in this tree
should I put this species?
Is it a bird?
Is it closer to eagle?
Should I put it closer to a bluebird,
and so on.
So classification of this kind
often has a top down, establish,
refine, establish,
refine connected to it.
>> So one of the benefits of this
establish and refine approach is it
helps us figure out which variables
we need to actually key in on and
focus in on.
So for example,
we saw earlier that eagles are large,
but bluebirds are small.
So birds can come in different sizes.
So if we are trying to establish whether
something is a bird, a reptile, or
a mamma, we know that mammals also come
in different sizes like tiny mice or
large elephants.
So size doesn't really impact our
decision whether it's a reptile, bird,
or mammal.
But once we've established it's a bird,
and
we're trying to decide between eagle and
bluebird for example, we know that size
actually can be something that helps
us differentiate between to these two.
So now we'll pay attention to
size as a variable that matters.
>> So note that there are several
things going on here.
On one side, there is knowledge of these
different classes, but there's also
organization of these different classes
in a hierarchical particular kind.
This organization is very
powerful in some ways.
If knowledge is power,
so is organization.
Organization too is power.
This organization provides power,
because this organization tells you what
the controller processing should be.
Establish one node, refine it.
Establish that node, refine it.